à cause de la pandémie et du confinement
le bien-être des français se détériore
depuis mars dernier
plus d'un millier d'études ont évalué
cette détresse psychologique due à
l'enfermement chez soi à la solitude à
l'incertitude en juin ont noté une
augmentation des dépressions du fait des
conséquences psychiatrique du
confinement les violences faites aux
femmes se sont multipliées les étudiants
confinés dans de petits logements
éloignés de leurs amis incapable de se
projeter dans l'avenir ont été
particulièrement touchés par cette
situation inédite selon l'étude une
équipe de chercheurs du centre et nous
sommes borders population 28 % des
étudiants se déclarent triste déprimé ou
désespéré plus la moitié du temps vous
voir tous les jours contre 15 % chez les
noirs étudiants
la psychologue hélène romano a participé
à la commission d' enquête initiée par
la députée communiste marie george
buffet afin de mesurer prévenir les
effets de la crise du conte vite sur la
jeunesse détail les conséquences du
confinement sur la santé mentale
on a beaucoup de demandes dans des
contextes roubles à peine anxieux de
phobie sociale de gens font peur de
sortir ont peur d'attraper le virus et
consoles plus que d'habitude de l'alcool
des psychotropes dévié et des drogues
cannabis donc on a plus de troubles
psychiques ans pendant mal
le psychiatre nicolas franck et chefs de
pôles au centre hospitalier le vinatier
à lyon a également travaillé sur ces
souffrances psychiques
il en réfère dans un livre qu vider
détresse psychologique aux éditions
odile jacob
alors que les choses se sont encore
aggravées avec le nouveau confinement
il souhaiterait aujourd'hui que les
pouvoirs publics prennent la mesure de
ce grave problème de santé publique
impose des restrictions extrêmement
important tous les français qui ne
peuvent plus circuler librement qu'ils
peuvent plus se rencontrer librement
hors l'être humain en effet ni pour être
enfermés ni pour être coupé des autres
je crois que la dimension de la santé
mentale est extrêmement importante parce
que là on touche tous les français ont
contraint tous les français on leur
impose une épreuve qui est difficile à
supporter donc il faut les accompagner
ça veut dire avoir une communication
pour leur permettre de remarquer des
manifestations d'une certaine difficulté
ça veut dire des dispositifs pour les
écouter et ça veut dire éventuellement
des soins appropriés pour chacun des
besoins durant le premier confinement un
certain nombre d'initiatives avait été
mise en place par des associations par
l'état
les plateformes téléphoniques d' écoutes
avait été ouverte
les consultations en psychiatrie dédié
aux coville existe toujours et pour le
reste très peu de projets dans le
domaine ont été créés ou reconduits
romano tire la sonnette d'alarmé y ait
des lieux pour les parents ont le
soutien à la parentalité ça c'est
extrêmement important pour aider les
parents à repérer les troupes savoir
comment ils parlent avec leurs enfants
et concrètement qu'il y avait pas
possibilité gratuite c'est très
important pour les parents les
enseignants et éventuellement d'avoir au
moins des plateformes téléphoniques ou
des structures d'accueil pour la
question des conséquences de confinement
pour l'instant ça n'existe pas au pays
des bisounours qu'il faudrait des moyens
pour les psy c'est à dire plus de psy a
recruté deux psychiatres les options de
psychologue c'est pas du tout la volonté
actuelle vraiment des lieux d'exil avec
des professionnels formés mi août un
rapport d'analysé du ministère de la
santé avait pourtant pointé les immenses
besoins qui sont nés durant la crise
elle est très nombreux domaines et
publics qui nécessite des compétences en
santé mentale
il s'agirait de traduire les intentions
en actes